erwarten sie haben da gestern für
massive aufregung gesorgt mit diesem
tweet als ich den gesehen habe dachte
ich was will er uns jetzt damit wieder
sagen was ist das für eine
verschwörungstheorie es geht um den
tweet den sie dort abgesetzt haben über
annalena baerbock
sie haben die initialen des
vollständigen namens anna lena charlotte
alma berbalk acab genannt und gefragt ob
damit vielleicht cops are bastards
gemeint sein könnten also alle
polizisten sind bastarde was hat sie auf
die idee gebracht
aus meiner sicht so etwas zu formulieren
dafür schon lieber herr und dass mir die
gelegenheit geben dazu etwas zu sagen
obwohl es vielleicht heute abend nicht
mehr passen blick ist weil ich zunächst
einmal gratulieren möchte uns
parteifreunden in magdeburg sachsen
anhalt und vor allem dem minister
prozent für einen history und kann man
fast sagen erfolg mag ich etwas dazu ist
sie im letzten wochen immer wieder
schiffe von unterstellt worden wenn ich
dies oder das hat man mir unterstellt
ich würde sich antisemitisch äußern in
was völliger unsinn
und deswegen habe ich gestern abend weil
ich gesehen habe dass passt wie habe ich
gesagt dieser abkürzung kann man genau
im sinn ich auch als schiffsverkehr aber
woher der massen sie haben das ja nicht
aufgeklärt sie haben das so stehen
lassen und nutze jetzt die gelegenheit
das aufzuklären und sie sprechen die
vorwürfe an die gegen sie erhoben wurden
sie haben im magazin cato das hängt mit
der jungen freiheit zusammen vor
wirtschaftsjournalisten bewahren zitat
deren ziele seien globale profite
zunehmend auf einige tausend familien zu
konzentrieren die sich daran machen weil
alles zu besitzen wenn meinen sie denn
mit so etwas konkret schauen sie mal
dieser artikel war ja in einer
amerikanisch breite von der stanford
university licht worden catterfeld fand
diesen beitrag wohl hoffentlich so gut
dass sie ins deutsche übersetzt hatten
und dann auch in deutschland publizieren
was ich damit und meinen mit
autor sagen wollte wir müssen uns
gedanken darüber machen in welche
richtung sich uns wirtschaft auch nur
unsere gesellschaft entwickelt und ich
glaube es ist offen
wenn man beiträge in davos anschaut von
von einigen personen die dort treten das
offensichtlich gleichwohl ziele verfolgt
werden unsere gesellschaftsordnung zu
verändern unter dem stichwort der großen
transformation aber das klingt doch nach
einer weltverschwörung
das ist wahnsinn das ist nach einer
reihe der diesjährigen völker schauen
sie mal das ist völlig und schaue mir
nur die reden in davos an
und wenn in davos gesagt wird wir müssen
hier cupid lag in europa und der welt
nutzt zum transformation an das ist
keine verschwörung dass eine tatsache
sie können sich diese videos anschauen
und darüber müssen uns gedanken machen
und es ist ich sag mal sind leugner
dieser diese diskussion wenn gesagt wird
es gibt keine derartige große formation
oder kein great reset ich bin der
auffassung wenn in davos öffentlich
diskutiert werden was auch in
deutschland tun und uns die frage
stellen wollen wir das und wie das aber
welche familien meinen sie denn wenn sie
das sagen
deren ziel sei es globale profite
zunehmend auf einige tausend familien zu
konnte konzentriert wen meinen sie denn
damit konkret also in diesem artikel
angesprochen dass es offensichtlich
personen in wall street in silicon
valley gibt große probleme mit der frage
demokratie haben ich bin ein verfechter
der freiheit demokratie
ich möchte nicht dort sehr sehr sehr
reiche personen die freiheit nicht
demokratie aussieht und das sehe ich als
mann
das sehe ich als ein problem an nachdem
ich mir einige reden wo es angehört